so in all honesty when i opened up that
email the other day
my heart nearly stopped
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here first of all thank
you so much for joining me
on this channel we talk about
architecture and technology
if that's something that interests you
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below
because today we're talking all things
architecture for those of you who are
actually longtime subscribers a quick
life update
i am 100 out of my moon boot my achilles
tendon is fully repaired semi
i'm back on my feet walking slowly with
a little bit of a limp
but i'm actually back on my feet which
is fantastic
i've recently sat my final exam to
become a fully registered architect in
western australia
and if you haven't guessed it already i
have been successful in
that attempt
so today we're talking about how and
what you need to do
to become a registered architect in
australia so let's start
way back at the beginning in australia
you need to have
two degrees you need to have an
undergraduate degree which is a
three-year
full-time course at most universities
around australia
and then you need to acquire a master's
degree which is another two years
full-time at most universities in
australia so
a total of five years at university
and a very large hex bill in all honesty
this is probably
the easiest part of the whole process
it's the time we actually get to enjoy
life
get to learn about what you're
passionate about and you just
really really get to learn about
architecture
so these first five years as hard as
they might seem
are definitely some of the best so enjoy
them and cherish them
i don't want to really spend too much
time on this bit because
once you're in university you're taught
about this what you're not taught about
is how and what the process is of going
from university
graduating as a masters of architecture
graduate and going all the way to a
fully registered architect
there's a lot of steps in between
there's a lot of things you need to
learn
so today let's go through that bit one
by one
first of all i sat all my exams here in
the state of western australia
with most architecture courses and the
title architect is protected in
different manners across the entire
world
and there is different regulations in
each state
so some things to what i say here may
differ in your state and they'll more
than likely differ in your country
so take what i say here with a grain of
salt and make sure you do your own
research first
anyway step one to becoming a registered
architect after you've
passed your master's degree is your
logbook and statement of practical
experience
your logbook is issued by the architects
board here in western australia
and it's a very long form that you
basically fill out every single day
after work
at least that's the best way i found to
fill it out if you leave it for too long
it ends up taking way too much of your
time to fill out but basically what the
logbook is
it's a couple pages about you and then
it's a couple pages
about 80 pages of logging your
experience
very similar to how you had to log your
driver's exam and every hour that you
did
so there's 15 performance criteria in
the logbook that you have to attend to
if you're studying under an architect
then it makes it very simple there's
three categories
you can fill in and you can pretty much
do
the 3300 hours that are minimum required
which is approximately two years full
time at 40 hours a week
pretty easily so the three categories
are executive level participant and
observer
they're all pretty self-explanatory as
well so the executive level you've done
everything yourself the participant
level you've participated in the event
and the observer level well obviously
you've just observed what's going on
i personally didn't study under an
architect i went into a building design
firm
with no technical registered architect
there to supervise me
which was i guess a good thing and a bad
thing in my experience
good thing being that i was given the
opportunity to
do every single bit of the practice and
learn
in my own way making sure that i had to
do all the research
find out what was the correct way of
doing it and then putting it as practice
the bad thing is i had to do all that
research i had to learn it all on my own
and there wasn't somebody
truly guiding me step by step i did have
a director that was very
caring and considerate throughout that
whole process and made the process
significantly easier than most of my
peers who have tried
to study under architects so i guess in
the long run and for me personally it
definitely worked out in my favor
but more to the point if you aren't
studying under architect it means you
can only log your hours under the
executive level
it means you have to be the decision
maker you have to do all the work
that doesn't usually happen at the start
so it takes a little bit of time for you
to get into practice
learn what you need to do and then be
able to start logging hours under
executive level what i've already
mentioned is there's 3
300 hours in the logbook as a minimum to
complete part 1.
what i didn't mention is that there's
three parts in the state of western
australia
and in australia in a whole i'm pretty
sure to complete your registration as an
architect
part one is very simple it is the log
book and your statement of practical
experience which i'll get into in a
second
part two is an online exam that is
usually done in a testing facility
and part three is examination by
interview now
full disclosure i passed part one and
part
two on my first go part three i sat last
year and
wasn't successful unfortunately in all
honesty i was
pretty well aware of the fact that i
wasn't going to pass that exam
when i came out of it i was extremely
nervous i wasn't confident
and i didn't know half the answers so
when i received that email
saying unfortunately it didn't pass that
was
it was heartbreaking but at the same
time i knew it was coming
this year it was definitely a different
story we'll keep going with that though
so the first time i finished my logbook
and went to sit part
two i had 3600 hours logged in my
logbook the second time
i had 6 300 hours logged
i worked my butt off the next year to be
able
to actually gain all the knowledge and
learn every single thing
that i needed to know about this exam it
was
the best year of my life because i
learned so much i absorbed so much
knowledge
and i became a much much better
practitioner so in order to go from part
one
to sit part two you have to submit your
logbook to the board
alongside the logbook you have to submit
a statement of practical experience
it's simply a word document of about two
thousand words
if you're studying under an architect or
three thousand if you're not
it is a very simple exercise it is go
through your logbook
look at the jobs that you've done that
are pretty major go through them
list them one by one pick maybe four or
five
of value and importance and then write a
little bit of a brief and a blurb about
them
which relates back to those 15 criteria
that i mentioned previously in the
logbook
upon completing the statement of
practical completion you submit that
your logbook
certified copies of all your documents
and everything else that the forms
require for sitting part two
and of course this doesn't come free it
comes at a price like everything in life
part two of the ape
or the architectural practical exam is
like i mentioned
an online exam at a testing facility now
i'm not allowed to disclose too much
about part two or part three
but what i can tell you is very
important
part two is five scenarios with six
questions on each scenario
and it is 60 minutes in total it is
usually sat in an enclosed testing
facility
supervised by highly experienced people
that way
they ensure that you can't cheat and
you're only looking at your own work
this year i think it was a little bit
different they may have said it
online because of covert i didn't see it
my part two this year i sat at last year
so i'm not actually aware of how they
did it this year there is
that potential of doing it online at
your own home but i'm guessing moving
forward once we continue to progress
out of covert we will definitely be
going back to those isolated
locked down testing facilities part two
is predominantly on
your knowledge of running a practice and
running a project
it is literally that simple if you can
understand the fundamentals of starting
a business
as an architect and an architectural
firm and understand the process
of managing a job from design
development all the way
to practical completion and project
handover is very important
the main things they do really really
hammer on
is project management because from the
industry's point of view
at least to my understanding that is the
point where most architects get sued and
that is the point
where most of us get a bad name so if
you know your stuff in project
management you're less
likely to end up in that category of bad
eggs
which is exactly what the institute is
looking for good graduates with
lots of experience so make sure you're
highly experienced
in project management and don't spend
all your time just sketching and drawing
yes being a good architect is sketching
and drawing but there's a lot more to it
that's actually one of the reasons
why i failed my original part 3 exam
because i didn't have all of those
project management experience and
knowledge originally i went into it i
believe with about 100 hours of
each category required for project
management
100 hours in the grand scheme of things
to understand project management
is nothing there are so many contracts
out there that you have to understand
read through legalities and bits and
pieces that you have
absolutely no idea what they mean until
they come up in real life
and you have to figure it out so make
sure that whatever firm you go to
starting out
or whatever firm you're in now if you're
going to sit your practical exam
get as much practical knowledge and
project management experience as
absolutely possible if this isn't an
option like it wasn't really an option
for me at the start
i invested in the powers program which
is run by the institute of architects
it is a pretty expensive course in my
personal opinion it's about
1200 from memory once you buy all the
bits and pieces that you have to to get
into it
but it is very very very valuable
from memory it's about 900 pages worth
of information
and about 80 hours of video content they
have
recently as of this year actually just
updated the powers program and the
course
so there is so much up-to-date
information that is definitely worth
knowing and reading
even if you're a completely educated
architect practicing
day in day out i do personally recommend
going back
and learning this information if you
have the spare time
because it is simply valuable to refresh
your knowledge
there's things i knew but completely
forgot so
again it is a very valuable resource if
you have
the financial means to afford this
course i'll leave a link for it down in
the description below
again i have no affiliation to this
course it's not like something i can
sell
it is run by the institute themselves
there's no promotions there's no schemes
it's literally
just a really really useful course for
you guys to do
if you need that added help now apa part
three
is the final examination by interview
it's simply conducted
as an interview it's yourself and two
highly experienced practitioners in
front of you
it is about a 45 minute to one hour
interview
where they literally just drill you with
questions
non-stop it isn't about really picking
at your flaws but it is
actually about picking up your flaws
what the interviewers are looking for on
the other side
is what don't you know where do you fall
short
and is that a problem for the institute
and the architect's protected title
if you know your stuff don't stress
you'll go through it
like a breeze when i went through it the
second time i came out extremely
confident i was like
i knew every question i was very
confident but at the same time because i
had that disappointment last year
i kept thinking to myself don't get too
hyped up
don't get too worked up and if you don't
pass it's still okay
you have another chance even though i
knew deep deep down that i did really
well
so what i'm trying to get across is know
your stuff
learn as much as you possibly can and if
you're going into that interview
prepared you should have no issues
if you're going under prepared and
haven't actually done
council work development applications
worked with high-end multi-residential
low-end multi-residential commercial
bits and pieces learn on the bits that
you aren't sure about because they're
probably going to ask some questions
about it
but overall the interview is very
similar to the apa part two
it's testing your knowledge on starting
a firm and it's testing your knowledge
on
the whole project experience as if i
were a new client coming to you
from day one to hand over so make sure
you go through and learn every detail
between a and z
because there's a good chance they'll
ask any question in between the spectrum
it isn't really something that you can
study for in just
book smarts you definitely need the
experience as well what happens once
you're registered
once you get that glorious email that i
received the other day
well from there on in it's pretty simple
you fill out some forms
you submit to the board for application
they review your application
hopefully they approve it you become a
registered architect and then every year
you have to complete a minimum of 20
continuous professional development
points the simplest way to explain that
is
one hour of professional development
equals one point
so if you go to a seminar that's two
hours long
then you get two points for it they give
you a certificate you keep that
information
and you have to provide it the next year
when you go to re-register
for the following year otherwise in a
nutshell that is basically the process
from day one
to the day you're registered it is an
extremely long process
it took me almost
eight years to complete so from day one
of architecture
five years at university and then
another three years of
actual practical experience which no lie
there are very different worlds
university and real life are very
very different you come out of
university thinking you know everything
you come out of the registration process
thinking oh i know nothing
so it is a very valuable lesson to learn
but
the eight years are extremely valuable
and such an amazing process
anyway that's all for me today guys i'm
completely out of breath
so i'm gonna call it a day if you
enjoyed the video make sure you smash
that like button down below to help this
video with the youtube algorithm
and if you want to see more of my
content smash that subscribe button down
below
hit the little bell if you want to be
notified and as always i'll see you next
monday